want to get into the best shape of your
life it's simple all you've got to do is
run four miles a date do a thousand
press ups and do a full body routine in
the gym lasting about an hour to an hour
and a half daily what
it's obviously writing a training
program that will get you ripped and
strong is fairly easy the problem is
writing one that you can actually stick
to and that isn't going to destroy your
body in the short term if you train too
hard it may lead to something called
overtraining except for the term
overtraining is somewhat controversial
because of course it is because
everything in Fitness is controversial
the problem is that a lot of people will
tell you overtraining doesn't exist it's
just an excuse for people who are too
wussy to work out every single day and
there's actually some truth to this
because the term overtraining
technically refers to a syndrome that
affects athletes at the top level so the
argument goes that if you can have a
top-tier athlete working out incredibly
intensely most days or if you can have
someone going through intense Special
Forces training and they don't generally
get overtraining then what are the
chances that you're gonna get over
trained actual overtraining
occurs at that level only and it results
in months of recovery as they become
demotivated depressed prone to injury
poor immune system etc is real serious
thing and chances are if you're just
going to the gym two to three times a
week you probably aren't over trained
not technically anyways
but if the conclusion you're drawing
from this is that you don't need to
worry about overtraining that you can
train as hard as you like and not worry
about the consequences then you've taken
a logical leap too far because whilst
overtraining might not be affecting you
there's a good chance that something
else is affecting me which is under
recovery which simply means you're not
fully recovered when you next return to
the gym and as we'll actually see there
are kinds of able training that can be
affecting you and to break it down to
say that it's not real and therefore you
shouldn't worry about it when it's
really just a matter of semantics is
pedantic and not particularly helpful
and certainly not sympathetic to people
who really do struggle with burnout and
injury that prevents them from making
progress in the gym so under recovery
can cause a range of different issues
and problems that will negatively affect
your training the first is that you
won't have time to recover from small
niggling injuries that can cause the
bigger problems
down the line because even if that
slight irritation in your knee isn't
causing you any serious gripe right now
it can cause corrective movement
patterns so you overcompensate for that
injury you move incorrectly and you thus
become more likely to injure yourself in
other ways or to exacerbate that
existing injury at the same time if
you're under recovered then you aren't
building and growing muscle to the same
extent because remember training is
biphasic that means that it takes two
stages the first is that you break down
the muscle tissue and you flood it with
metabolites you send that stimulus to
grow and the second phase is of course
the recovery when you actually grow when
the protein synthesis occurs when you
restore those muscle tissues those
muscle fibers without that recovery
phase all you're doing is breaking down
and damaging the muscle and never giving
it the chance to restore itself when you
would turn to the gym if you're under
recovered you'll be weaker again more
likely to injure yourself and of course
less likely to make positive progress on
your various different lifts at the same
time you may experience something called
adrenal fatigue at least to some extent
when you're in the gym you're in an
aroused State you're in a sympathetic
state so your sympathetic nervous system
is kicked in and that means you're
producing adrenaline and cortisol and
dopamine and things that make you ramped
up revved up and ready to lift and as
we've seen in studies in previous videos
and articles adrenaline helps you to
lift heavier weights if you have more
adrenaline you can lift heavier so if
you're under recovered you're not gonna
be able to lift as much and you're not
going to make as much progress and
eventually this can get worse and worse
as we're gonna see later in this video
so I used to train really hard and never
worry about recovery when I was younger
I was so addicted to training that I
would do a night out at university and
stay out till 4:00 a.m. drinking heavily
and then if I hadn't done my workout
that day I would do it that night when I
got home drunk at 4:00 a.m. and then I'd
wake up the next day at 10:00 and go and
have one of those big survivor's
breakfasts so I was really dedicated to
my training and I never burned out it
never became an issue I never injured
myself I've never had any problems today
things have changed a little bit these
days if I train too hard
I find myself burning out or getting
injured and I have to take weeks off of
the gym or just take it slower for weeks
I lose all my games lose all my progress
and I know
that this happens again and again I'm
someone who tends to get all excited
about my training make loads of progress
then I'll have some small setback I need
to take tons of time off and it's
depressing Elliott Hulse talked about
this in one of his videos and he said
that it's a bit like having seasons your
body has seasons where you have a season
of Plenty where you have tons of energy
and you hit it hard but then you have a
season where you need to take it a bit
easier and recover and that certainly
rang true for me I found myself going
through these cycles and every time I
try and make decent progress every time
I started to reach my one rep Max's and
bulk up I'd hurt myself and have to stop
this was quite depressing and I made the
assumption that it was to do with
getting older and 30 now which isn't
super old but it's definitely older than
I was when I was 18 that's just
undeniable Matt's counting even it's not
even maths so I assumed that I was
getting older and thus I was you know my
hormone balance might not be so good
that my metabolism might not be so good
that picked up more injuries along the
way where are these by the way because I
severely broke my right wrist when I was
15 I've got a knee injury which often
prevents me from squatting of things I
thought I'm just getting older but then
I realised that that's probably not
actually the case because the difference
is that I'm not recovering properly
anymore C University I might have
trained hard and I might have gone out
on nights out but then afterwards I
would have as much time as I wanted to
lie in I'd do like three lectures a week
or four or five lectures a week there
like an hour to two hours long the rest
of the time you could sleep I mean that
uni that was the only time I remember
other than being a baby though I take
regular afternoon naps and then
immediately after I left University I
was self-employed still living with my
mate and just lying around again I used
to sleep in till 1:00 p.m. and my work
was a lot less intense these days on the
other hand though I have a much more
regular schedule I wake up early in the
morning and my work has got a lot more
intense I work the same amount that I
used to and then on top of that I do my
work friends or Authority and I'm
writing a book and I've got a mortgage
to pay and just a lot more
responsibilities a lot more active I
live further away I'm visiting people at
the time and yeah so I have less time to
recover when I'm not training although
I'm not
in the gym I'm not necessarily relaxing
as often and chances are the same might
be true for you if you've noticed that
you aren't getting muscle as easily as
you did when you were younger if you
keep injuring yourself chances are but
it's to do with your recovery because
this is the big point I want to make in
this video recovery doesn't just mean
that you're not in the gym in order to
recover you need to actually rest and
you need to actually feed yourself and
you need to get proper sleep and you
can't be stressed because essentially as
far as your body's concerned as far as
your physiology is concerned being
stressed about work rushing off on a big
commute that's like a workout your
parasympathetic nervous system and your
sympathetic nervous system kick in based
not only on whether or not you're
training but whether or not there is a
perceived threat and/or a perceived
thing that need to pursue something
interesting something that arouses you
so if you're taking time off the gym but
you're also working a nine-to-five job
and you have a very stressful and busy
commute there and back and you spend
your evenings staring at a screen with
lots of loud noises and colors and
you're worried about your debt and
you're worried about your relationships
and you're worried about what's going on
at work and you keep checking your email
and you don't get proper sleep then
you're not recovering you're actually
still in an aroused State you're still
in a catabolic state when you need to be
anabolic in order to recover so you need
to peak and be highly stressed and
aroused and active when you're in the
gym that's why we take pre workouts to
get ourselves a revved up but then when
you finish the workout you need to be
calm and you need to be relaxed and like
I've said before you need to live like a
lion that means you should be lounging
around eating all the time not letting
your blood sugar dip not being stressed
out by things and this is something that
most of us can't do anymore so if you're
not recovering from the gym anymore it's
probably to do with your lifestyle
outside of the gym and that's why
overtraining is a very real threat even
if you aren't an Olympic athlete many
other things contribute to this most of
us are dehydrated statistically most of
the UK and US are chronically dehydrated
many of us don't eat as much as we
should either eat as well as we should
this hampers our recovery too
most of us aren't getting enough sleep
and caffeine by the way is effectively
stress in a mug
if you use caffeine to wake yourself up
early in the morning then you're
triggering your fight-or-flight response
to a degree and again you're not in a
state of recovery or in heightened
cortisol which means lowered
testosterone I'm guilty of this too I
love caffeine but it isn't useful if
you're trying to recover and regain
muscle and regain energy so you can
return back to the gym this actually all
leads to something that's referred to as
21st century
syndrome 21st century syndrome is
essentially adrenal fatigue and it means
that we're so wired so on all the time
most of us on a daily basis that we are
strung out wrung out and we actually
lose our ability to produce adrenaline
and other key hormones and
neurotransmitters that help us to be
alert and focused so if you make that
busy commuting to work where thousands
of people are walking towards you and
cars are honking and you're breathing
and smoke and toxins and then you get
into work and you drink a big strong mug
of coffee which gets your heart rate
racing and then your boss shouts it in
you're like ah and the first thing that
woke you up in the morning was an alarm
beeping loudly first thing just shocking
you out of a deep sleep and then all day
at work you're just stressed getting
emails and people calling you and then
you come home and you're just tired but
you wired at the same time because you
don't really been doing any exercise and
you're staring at a screen playing candy
crush that's a dated reference but you
know I mean getting constant
notifications on your phones still
checking your work email baby's crying
or whatever your bank managers angry at
you then that's gonna lead eventually to
your body being unable to produce the
hormones that keep you aroused and alert
and this leads to brain fog it leads to
lower the immune system so you more
likely to become ill it leads to stress
of course it leads to depression and
this is actually a form of adrenal
fatigue and all that overtraining is is
a form of adrenal fatigue so you can
actually be able to trained from life
even before you stack on top of that
three four five one hour long sessions
in the gym that are making you even more
stressed even more exhausted so yeah
maybe overtraining isn't technically
likely to affect you in the conventional
sense but the whole gamut of your life
of your
all adding up if it's stressful and
you're not recovering then yeah you're
gonna get injured you're not going to be
building muscle as effectively and it's
going to make a huge difference to your
training and you're not going to see
those gains that you want to see so what
is the solution well of course you could
become freelance like me you could work
for yourself from there you don't have
the nasty commute and you can decide
which hours you want to work I just did
a video on that so check that out if
you're interested but I do realize
that's not an option for most people so
fortunately there are other options and
the key thing is just to be more mindful
of all this and to be more aware of how
you're recovering when you're taking the
time off of the gym to not only not be
at the gym but also to be actually
recovering so one way you do this is by
making sure you get enough sleep and
countless studies have shown that when
you sleep more you perform better
athletes who aim for eight or even ten
hours of sleep see performances in their
speed their reaction times their aim so
check out the article that accompanies
this video linked in the description
down below and that will tell you more
about that and link to those studies at
the same time you need to be eating more
a lot of people who aren't recovering
properly who are injuring themselves
often in the gym simply aren't eating
enough and you'd be surprised what a
difference just adding some more
calories and some more protein and more
nutrition can make to your recovery
because a body uses amino acids from the
protein in order to restore and rebuild
muscle tissue of course and to heal
injuries at the same time all those
nutrients perform many different
important roles like vitamin D for
instance is technically more of a
prohormone and it regulates the
testosterone it can help you with that
recovery magnesium will help you to
sleep better and to relax more so if
you're not eating a nutrient-dense diet
then you're much more likely to get worn
out and wired and damaged more quickly
at the same time you just need calories
in order to fuel all these processes to
feel the workouts but also to feel your
actual recovery process drinking more
water is very important as I said
already most of us are dehydrated if you
drink more water water isn't is
important for nearly every single
chemical reaction in the body is crucial
for digestion for absorbing nutrients
for breaking down food it's crucial for
muscle tissue hypertrophy
so if you're not drinking enough then
you're gonna be in trouble too in the
actually you're gonna be in a state of
slight stress same as if you're not
getting enough sleep so you need to make
sure you're sleeping properly make sure
you're getting enough water make sure
getting enough nutrition if you want to
go even further then you can avoid
caffeine personally I'm not willing to
go that far because I'm badly addicted
and I love it
you can turn off your phone in the
evening so that you're not being
stressed out by that light or at least
get one of those blue blocking filter
apps that will use the red shift on the
screen so it's not causing that trigger
in cortisol so things like this helping
yourself to actually recover will make a
big difference meditation can help a
huge amount because it helps you to
respond to stress better and to notice
it and to calm yourself back down CBT
can help box breathing which I talked
about recently can help and supplements
can help things that boost testosterone
will make you more anabolic so that's
also an option but one of the best
things you can do is just take a D load
week every now and then in fact I
recommend about once every six weeks so
delayed week just means one week where
you're either not training at all or
you're only training with things that
aren't going to stress you out aren't
gonna cause physiological damage aren't
gonna risk injury so that might mean
things like stretching or brain training
or you know yoga or something like that
something gentle or like I say just take
the time literally off use it to do some
reading
a lot of people will be resistant to
this idea but actually it can prevent
you from having to take much more time
off later on down the line taking a week
off isn't going to damage your muscle
gains it takes about two to three weeks
to start losing muscle and that's not
even counting my nuclei which will stick
around possibly indefinitely no one's
really sure and make it much easier if
you do regain any muscle that you do
lose anyways so there's not gonna be any
loss there's no downside to doing this
but at the same time you'll recover from
those injuries you'll give your adrenal
system a chance to recover as well and
at the same time during this time you
can also focus on just being good to
yourself taking time out trying to
reduce the amount of stress in your life
and like I say living like a lion so if
you want to if people leaves asking the
question I'm going on holiday for a week
or for two weeks should I train the
answer is absolutely not this is the
perfect time go to
all inclusive holiday eat all the meat
lie around in the Sun go in the sauna
and just relax and don't worry about
anything that's the perfect time to grow
to really focus on growing just as
important as if it was a training
routine is that recovery because that's
when you grow and that's when you
prevent yourself from getting seriously
damaged and consider as well that you
can reduce the amount of stress in your
life in other ways and likewise think
about how your workouts are affecting
your productivity because it does cut
both ways if you're training really hard
and are dreaming and draining your
adrenal glands then this is going to
affect your butt it's to focus at work
as well you just might be doing too much
you might need to reprioritize what's
important to you what can you cut can
you reduce some of those commitments can
you just take some time for yourself
it'll make a big difference
and listen to your body if you notice
yourself getting injured more easily if
you notice that you're feeling rundown
then take a week off even if you haven't
scheduled a D load week and you can
actually use a hand dynamometer to test
your cortisol to testosterone ratio
which gives you a good idea as to
whether you're sympathetic or
parasympathetic dominant in other words
are you recovered or are you still
stressed and aroused and are you ready
to go back to the gym I did a video on
this before so I'll link to that in the
description down below
but again just listen to your body if
you feel energetic and full of life
you're good to go back to the gym if you
think man this workout isn't going so
well I feel like I'm gonna injure myself
then stop go home and take some time off
I just want to close by saying there are
huge individual differences here some
people can train really hard have really
busy lives never worry about recovery
and it never seems to be an issue for
them other people they do the slightest
bit of work and they injure themselves
and this comes down to lots of different
things such as how you respond to stress
your hormone balance and just the
resiliency of your tissue some of it can
be trained and improved with the time
and some of it you're just gonna have to
manage and you know play the hand that
you were dealt so I talked in a previous
video on flow States about how the top
performers both in athletics and in
Special Forces those people who are able
to get more aroused more alert during
competitive activities but then also to
become more parasympathetic dominant
when they're at rest in all
to relax more and to recover more so
these top performers their secret is
that they are more aroused when they
need to be on and they're more relaxed
when they need to be off so this is
again a sign of just how important is to
chill and to recover and again how much
of an impact individual differences make
and when you think about it what are
steroids anabolic steroids raise
testosterone which is the most anabolic
hormone it's all about recovery it's all
about rebuilding tissue in your downtime
and these of course are the people
people who take steroids although they
have many downsides and not recommending
them you can see the huge benefits it
makes in terms of strength and muscle
gain so that just goes to show the
biggest hack to building muscle is all
about emphasizing recovery so that's
what you need to do you need to
emphasize recovery and enhance your
hormonal balance and maybe look into
things like CBT and box breathing I've
talked about some of those concepts on
this channel before in order to improve
your ability to recover as well as
prioritizing it in your programming and
just be more mindful of how stressed and
busy you are the rest of the time if you
want to prioritize your physical
performance thanks a ton for watching
guys hope fans feeling useful
interesting if you did then please leave
a like please share it around that helps
me immensely comment down below and let
me know what tips you have for enhancing
recovery thanks turn again for
everything you've done so far all the
comments they keep you going they
inspire me to keep making more videos
chatting to me on the Facebook group
check out the links to the social media
down below by the way and on Instagram
really appreciate it we're at 30
thousand subscribers nearly now so
there's loads of a mentum it's really
exciting and have you guys to thank for
it so yeah it's awesome if you want to
see more videos like this then hit
subscribe hit the bell button for
notifications of course I'll be covering
more topics on strength training
bodybuilding Fitness performance
calisthenics martial arts all that usual
stuff as well as brain training
productivity technology VR nootropics
working online if that all sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now